[Music]
while mainstream media focuses on
Trump's locker-room talk and Clinton's
emails there are actually a whole slew
of other interesting political stories
happening right now related to the
presidential election this election has
seen a massive shift in America's
political alignment on both the left and
the right on the Left we've seen a real
divide between the Bernie wing of the
Democrats in the Clinton camp Bernie's
message against Wall Street money in
politics and his chastising of the
political establishment has been
swallowed wholly by the political
Clinton machine while bernie is now
supporting Hillary it's pretty clear
that many of his supporters aren't
following his lead in either donations
or enthusiasm this division is one of
the reasons Hillary is still struggling
with young people and overall connecting
with new voters meanwhile on the right
we've seen the absolute fracturing of
the Republican Party as we know it
mainstream Republicans like Paul Ryan
John McCain and Jeb Bush are now on the
outside looking in
as Trump has aggressively gutted the
party it's pretty clear that if Trump
wins in November the old guard of the
Republicans will be out and his inside
circle of people like Rudy Giuliani
chris Christie and ben Carson will be in
while the list of Republicans not voting
for Trump continues to grow the
Republican base who voted during the
primaries is still with him and whether
the party is supporting Trump or not
those people are Trump's rise also
fractured the Republican Party
ideologically neo-cons are either in
hiding or defecting to Hillary while the
Christian conservatives are backing
Trump a candidate who is probably their
last choice when this election began
let's not forget this is a guy who
compared his own book to the Bible as
they say politics makes strange
bedfellows for both the Democrats and
the Republicans 2016 will be looked back
on as a watershed year regardless of who
wins it's clear the parties are in flux
and they both desperately need new ideas
and new leaders the fact that we have a
69 year old Democrat running against a
70 year old Republican tells you all you
need
to know about the aging state of our
two-party system how is it that these
two were the best star system concern
out while it's easy to mock Millennials
just imagine how you would feel if this
was the first presidential election you
ever really paid attention to or had a
chance to vote in we've got the ultimate
reality star running against the
ultimate insider and while they may hate
each other they're also perfect for each
other by the time this thing is over
they'll have thrown out everything but
the kitchen sink but that'll only be
because they needed it to wash their
dirty hands one of the many issues which
seems to have been almost totally
shelved during this campaign is science
I guess in some ways science is the
obvious sacrificial lamb in an election
contest focusing so much on mudslinging
instead of discussing the actual issues
that affect our lives as we discussed
during my chat with transhumanists all
tennis fan two weeks ago there are so
many huge upcoming scientific
breakthroughs coming down the pike from
stem cell research to cloning to
artificial intelligence that we must
talk about these issues now so that
we'll know how to deal with the
ramifications of them both good and bad
when they're right in front of us
scientific breakthroughs will continue
to happen whether we're prepared for
them or not
perhaps we can never be fully prepared
but we at least need leaders who believe
in the merits of science in the first
place my guest this week is theoretical
physicist Lawrence Krauss Krauss is the
foundation professor in the school of
Earth and space exploration and physics
department at Arizona State University
as well as the director of the origins
project at ASU which focuses on the
origins of humans and the universe
itself Krauss has been outspoken this
election related to politics and science
particularly the seeming lack of
knowledge in this department by Donald
Trump we're gonna dive deep both into
science and politics as well as the many
places that the two intersect I figure
if a guy can spend his adult life trying
to figure out the mysteries of the
universe then maybe just maybe he can
figure out the mysteries of our current
political existential crisis
you
[Music]